with their courage and how they uh a
choice a resilience and resolved for
their future
and the American people have stood
proudly with them
Democrats and Republicans together with
our allies in Europe and Japan and other
places
to make sure you have the financial
humanitarian and security assistance
that if needed we're going to talk about
that today and we're going to continue
to strengthen Ukraine's ability to
defend itself particularly air defense
and that's why we're going to be
providing Ukraine with Patriot missile
batter
training you're forces to be able to
accurately use it together with our
partners we're also going to continue to
impose costs on the Kremlin and we'll
support Ukrainian pursuing a just peace
president zielinski the United States
stands with the great people in Ukraine
we stand with you and have been a great
leader and by the way
we have a famous thing that occurs once
a year to pick the man of the year in
Time Magazine you are the men of the
year in this in the United States of
America
welcome we have a lot to talk about it
as far as yours thanks so much
so rather than great honor for me
to be here
your journalists I thank you so much for
invitation I really
wanted to come further Mr President
knows about you but I couldn't do it
because the situation was so difficult
and now if I'm calm came I mean that we
control the situation and because of
support and first of all because of your
support and I really
I understand that we have very important
topics and we'll discuss them everything
so many challenges in Ukraine in Europe
in the world
from energy to
today's on battlefield but but I first
of all I really all my appreciations
from my heart from the heart of
ukrainians all ukraines from our Nations
strong Nations all negotiations to you
first of all Mr President for your big
support
and Leadership of course Europe many
countries
helped us and are helping now because
the world's not nowhere it's a bit but
anyway but
that is your leadership thank you first
of all
thank you so much Mr President of course
thanks my brothers and support thanks
Congress and and thanks
from our just
Ordinary People to your ordinary
people
house I really appreciate
I think it's very difficult to to
understand what does it mean when we say
appreciate but
but you really have have to feel it and
thank you so much great honor to be here
and yesterday I was on the bus in
Buffalo that is the place all these or
country you know it all the details
we had so many phone calls and all
detail about it and I want to give you
something
one guy he's really really hero real
Captain
and he asked me to pass his award
and he asked me to best use the word
President Biden
and you will understand
AC captain of heimer's battery
yes he's very brave and he said give it
to very brave president and I want to
give you that at the cross
across from military
married
that is one oh God yes that is from him
and and I have the least he wrote the
list yes I didn't read Mr President I
can't read
it's not my kids in Ukrainian language
but hear the translation
his name is I have his name yes yes
whoa
undeserved but much appreciated thank
you thank you thank you thank you he
said that's all many his brothers
this system saved so thank you very much
well we have a tradition here and I will
give it to him
my son who fought in Iraq
they have what they call a Command coin
you see it on the battlefield I will
make sure that he gets one of those
right again thank you thank you so much
appreciate it what a great honor thank
you
well thank you press
another problem
[Music]
[Music]
thank you please come this way please
come this way did you move please keep
it moving this way thank you thank you
thank you